tiens christophe priou merci à monsieur
le président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre la semaine
dernière le gouvernement a notamment
introduit en 4 min dans le cadre de la
discussion du projet de loi relative à
la biodiversité
un amendement remettant la notion de
préjudice écologique en cause le tout
noyé dans un texte de 74 article
amendement précipitamment retiré
on peut néanmoins s'interroger sur les
intentions premières
ne croyez-vous pas que de tenter
d'effacer le principe du pollueur payeur
revient à donner un chèque en blanc à
tous ceux qui auront peu de scrupules à
prévenir le risque de pollution liés à
leur activité
c'est un coup dur après une bataille de
15 années suite au naufrage de l'erika
puis du prestige un combat juridique qui
a abouti en septembre 2012 à décision
d'un cour de cassation
reconnaissant le préjudice écologique en
mai 2013
à l'initiative du sénateur bruno
retailleau le sénat a voté à l'unanimité
une proposition de loi visant à inscrire
le préjudice psychologique et son
indemnisation dans le code civil
mon collègue alain leboeuf et moi même
avons déposé une proposition de loi
similaire en janvier 2013
conforme au texte adopté au sénat un
article unique 3 alinéa jamais inscrite
à l'ordre du jour car la garde des
sceaux madame christiane taubira avaient
promis début 2013 de présenter un texte
relative à la responsabilité civile
environnementale pour la fin de l'année
christiane taubira non c'est à nouveau
un texte en février 2015
on attend toujours c'est un recul
environnemental majeur porté vol par
votre gouvernement monsieur le premier
ministre si c'est une erreur et
dommageable si c'est une stratégie elle
est pitoyable
merci la parole est à madame barbara
pompili secrétaire d'état chargé des
relations internationales sur le climat
et de la biodiversité
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
christophe priou je vous
rassure et j'excuse par la même ségolène
royal qui est au sommet franco italien
le principe pollueur payeur n'est pas en
danger
il a d'ailleurs je vous le rappelle une
valeur constitutionnelle de même les
procédures qui existent aujourd'hui pour
permettre aux personnes physiques aux
entreprises aux collectivités de
demander réparation des préjudices
qu'elles subissent ne sont aucunement
remis en cause ce que nous sommes en
train de faire monsieur le député cdh
inscrire dans notre registre à sion un
nouveau droit
le préjudice écologique c'est un droit
que nous reconnaissons à la nature de
voir ribes arrêt ou compenser les
conséquences d'atteinte à
l'environnement
il s'agit d'un principe très important
introduit dans la loi de diversité à
l'initiative d'un sénateur vous l'avez
dit qui a eu comme vous monsieur priou
l'expérience du drame de l'erika la
volonté du gouvernement c'est de
garantir dans la loi cette avancée pour
l'écologie qui est aujourd'hui
jurisprudentielle la définition et la
portée de la notion de préjudice
écologique doivent permettre de
compenser réellement d'éventuels
préjudices tout en garantissant aux
entreprises une un cadre juridique clair
l'amendement gouvernemental qui a été
déposée pour préciser la rédaction du
sénat a donné lieu à des interprétations
divergentes et suscité des inquiétudes
fortes
ségolène royal et moi-même n'entendons
ni dramatiser ni corps et ses
inquiétudes
c'est pourquoi pour lever toute
ambiguïté l'amendement a été retiré
ainsi que tous les autres amendements
parlementaires pour prendre le temps de
définir ans avec les parlementaires
impliqués sur le sujet une rédaction
qu'il est toute ambiguïté et qui sera
présenté lors de l'examen en séance
nous y parviendrons dans la sérénité et
dans la concertation c'est la méthode
adoptée par ségolène royal depuis la
genèse de ce projet de loi et qui
continuera à être suivi
il n'est pas question d'amoindrir ce
droit qui sera un droit en plus et qui
n'entend les mêmes occasions
la parole est à monsieur christophe
castaner